okay right now top five uh
i would say
my homes
and then i would put josh allen second
then i'll put like rodgers
rogers might be ahead a josh allen to be
honest with you okay roger's my homes
josh
i ain't gonna put it in order cause it's
just so hard it's just a five okay but
then i would say kyler
and then i would say like my fifth ones
like tied at fifth
because like they've been through a lot
this past year would be like lamar and
dad
no joe burrow
no
why doesn't he crack
the top
joe's like extremely good
but like some games
joe would like have a day but in some
games like
he's not there
um
tell me more about how you know when
those not there games are happening
against the bears
he do like i don't know i wouldn't say
it's easy getting his head because i
haven't played him and i played him next
year so i want this to get to him and
he'd come out here down to
18 stadium and throw for 400 and be like
he said that in an interview so i don't
want to say nothing crazy but i would
just say like i don't know i think he's
past i think in the playoffs he's been
tremendous yeah like
but there's a few games early on that
like
i don't know he kind of said it was the
confidence in his knee which i believe
it like yeah and you kind of saw like he
wasn't trying to run
mm-hmm
and things like that but i think he's
kind of over that hunk
so i'm gonna look for it next year but i
think he's a top 10 quarterback for sure
for sure and he's climbing the ranks
like but to just throw him in the top
five already it's kind of like crazy